what did you get Mila for Valentine's
Day do you all do you all exchange gifts
though
tonight I know I know but she won't she
doesn't watch I'm not she's not I'm not
brave no no I'm not risking it I feel
like she might like meaningful I feel
like what do you get each other you've
been together for so long it's like a
really okay see here's the thing she's
like a really
um she's a very specific Gift Giver like
it's not about like what something is
how big it is it's like not about the
show it's about like does it have
meaning like absolutely example so for
Christmas she was like her best friend
and her uh manager
they used to always have this emergency
place that they would go to if there was
ever an emergency and it was in front of
Lucille Ball's house like right in
Beverly Hills like if there was an
emergency let's meet in front of Lucille
Ball's house that was the thing this is
the actual incredible part of the story
by the way okay but okay so here's the
thing so we're dry we drive by this
house every day on the way to take our
kids to school yeah and she's out and
one day we drop out and they're tearing
the house down and we're like oh my God
they're tearing down Lucille Ball's
house like we and she's like I I need to
go I need it for for Christmas I need to
get them the bricks from Lucille Ball's
house because they're tearing it down
and I'm I'm thinking to myself like how
are we going to get the brakes from it's
like a construction site it's all fenced
off so I sneak into the construction
site and I steal like three bricks from
the construction site and I'm like and I
put them in the back of my truck and I
go home like baby I got something for
you
I got you the brakes and so and she's
like oh my God you got me these bricks
this is the most amazing thing in the
world
so she packages them up and puts them in
these little boxes and puts a little tab
says Lucille balls house on it and then
gives it to her friends
she gives it to her friend
and we find out that wasn't Lucille
Ball's house that was the house across
the street from Lucio ball's house and
so I stole some random bricks from Eddie
cantor's house and I'm like what is
going on like I but which makes it a way
better story yeah it does but so then
she changed the plaque and it says not
Lucille Ball's house on it and but those
are the kind of sentimental things so
it's very detail-oriented I think that's
very cool it's
that'd be meaningful it's got to have
like some resin even if you're it's
intentional but it's another even if
it's not the steel balls yeah it's fine
I just love that was their meeting place
that's going to be a question next time
I talked to her
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going home
[Music]